nous arrivons donc maintenant à la
mesure phare de cette loi et nous y
arrivons après six jours complets de
débat pendant lesquels le gouvernement a
rejeté une par une toutes les
propositions de financement des
retraites toutes les propositions qui
éviteraient de faire opposer
l'intégralité de l'effort demandé sur
les millions de travailleurs et surtout
de travailleurs modeste qui dès
septembre devont trimer deux ans de plus
parce que c'est ça votre effort c'est
pas changer le travail c'est pas plus de
justice c'est faire de la casse sociale
par de la brutalisation démocratique
taxer des dividendes c'est non faire
surcotiser les eaux salaires c'est non
rendre contraignante l'égalité salariale
c'est non augmenter les salaires c'est
encore non mais faire trimer deux ans de
plus les plus précaires pour rembourser
ce que vous avez donné aux riches ça
c'est oui et ça personne n'en veut dans
le pays pas même vos électeurs à chaque
prise de parole du gouvernement dans
cette hémicycle l'opposition grandit
dans le pays elle ne cesse de
s'amplifier aujourd'hui 245
000 personnes Marseille 120 000 à
Toulouse 100.000 à Lille 100.000 à
Bordeaux 12000 personnes à Annonay
monsieur le ministre 700 000 à Paris il
y avait même des centaines de personnes
mobilisées à Bruxelles à Londres à
Madrid des Françaises et des Français de
l'étranger qui savent très bien dans
leur pays quels sont les conséquences
des pays qui ont décidé de reculer l'âge
de départ à la retraite plus de 3
millions de personnes dans la rue
aujourd'hui malgré les difficultés pour
tant d'entre elles de faire grève pour
dire une chose nous ne vous laisserons
pas nous prendre les deux meilleures
années de nos retraites pour les
remplacer par les deux pires années de
travail et je vais vous dire vous avez
un choix très simple retirez la réforme
maintenant vous aurez la honte passagère
de l'humilité trop tardive
entêtez-vous contre le pays entier et
vous aurez le déshonneur à jamais un
pays brisé et une démocratie au bord de
l'explosion retirez cette réforme
maintenant
[Musique]